well turning overseas to beirut lebanon
it was nearly destroyed by civil war in
the 1970s and 80s and this morning there
are fears those terrible days could
return fighting between rival militias
in beirut killed six people yesterday
the worst violence of its kind in years
holly williams is in beirut which is
already a city on the edge of disaster
holly good morning
good morning today here in lebanon
at this funeral but yesterday the center
of beirut this country's capital looks
like a war zone
the protesters were supporters of
hizballah which is backed by iran
on the streets of beirut they clashed
with rival groups
terrified residents were caught in the
crossfire and finally the army moved in
to restore a semblance of calm
the violence was sparked by an
investigation into this
a giant blast last year fueled by
dangerous chemicals stored in unsafe
conditions killing over 200 people and
laying waste to entire neighborhoods
survivors claimed government corruption
and negligence were to blame but
yesterday's protesters believe the judge
who's investigating the disaster is
biased and targeting politicians allied
with his bola problem with the judge
you're saying you don't trust the judge
you don't trust this investigation
no no i no no never
for two years lebanon's economy has been
in free fall one of the worst financial
crises the world has seen since the
1800s there were regular power blackouts
shortages of food medicine and fuel and
runaway inflation
a hundred dollars got us two million
lebanese pounds today a year ago it
would have been around a hundred and
fifty thousand disaster disaster
disaster exhaustion
money changer ibrahim sabah blames
lebanon's government
corruption
stealing whatever whatever
the fear is that lebanon's crisis could
further destabilize this fragile region
this country shares borders with war
torn syria and with israel for cbs
morning's holly williams beirut
holly williams for us in the thick of it
once again this time from beirut holly
thank you very much